human beings are disposable man and
symbiote combined this is a new race
your species the higher life-form
I just have to talk about it y'all I saw
y'all joking around
please tell me on set y'all we're having
as much fun as I just saw y'all have
them right here we've waited until now
we didn't break character yesterday Tom
this role what about it particularly
intrigued you what about the venom
character I think he just looks
brilliant I like the look of him as a
character he's got massive teeth to them
he's huge he's he bites people's heads
off he's got those eyes going on and I
think he's I just enjoy looking at him
to be fair so there was no character
before I turned up and then nothing on
the page really just this wonderful
experience came from the the character
was based aboard geometry was the Jekyll
and Hyde aspect of the inner conflict
between a human being and technically
something film which has no ethical
framework or no morality whatsoever but
comes from a soul one can argue is it
our higher being because it's from outer
space or if it's just literally primal
and and it's symbolic for me of of my
inside voice or others inside voices
where we can do whatever we want
whenever we want if we if we want but we
can't because social symbolic order
netiquette says that Esther you have to
play --have in a certain way so the fun
of this character is being able to play
between
between you know a human being and an
alien mistress running wire all over the
place if you're gonna stay you will only
hurt bad people I just have to start as
I said I'm the biggest beep fan I know
that it was amazing but what do you
think Dan Egan we think about Menem Dan
Egan probably would be so I mean just
his manhood would be so threatened by
venom for sure I think so too
yeah he would try to go toe-to-toe yeah
back down Dan like he always does would
talk a huge game and then in the end he
would he would complete flake all right
who's got the filthier mouth venom or
Selina Kyle oh man listen Lida Myers
Lana Meyer who I'd say Selina Meyer
actually yeah what I mean in venom
Venom's badass and he's you know he's
he's big tough you know body guy but I
mean some of the stuff that comes out of
Selena's mouth is just like makes your
skin crawl
are you bummed not spoiler alert that
you didn't get a symbiote moment uh no
you know i did i mean you know dan gets
to get gets to play with with venom
enough yeah yeah and I mean oh no you
know I mean who knows what the story's
told on doctor Dan maybe maybe a whole
cuz there was a lot of rumors so you saw
the rumors online oh yeah yeah
that power it's not completely awful you
have no idea how much you're scaring me
right now and then your character are
like I've seen you play like ambiguous
bad guys and like kind of bad guys but
this is like full-on villain so tell me
about what drew you to this line you may
appear villainous to lots of people by
cheese is driven he's ambitious he's got
good intentions no one thinks that a bad
guy yeah then he's trying to make sure
the humans have got somewhere to go
after we've destroyed planet Earth
really so you should be thanking him and
not calling him a villain
oh I will I won't think his methods I'll
thank you thank you because you're
really good it's really great in it
[Laughter]
[Music]
you